[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
going loud
talk it down
[Music]
um
that's a kill right there
[Music]
hey i got one
they'll never see what's coming
[Applause]
what more do you want with me
[Applause]
[Music]
what was that thing
and now
an opportunity
on your feet
take him to my tower
to get in we need to activate the graph
lift
hmm
the protocol's not banished in origin
it's
sturdier than i expected
problem
no problem
sorry
let's go
we're in
wow
this place is
exactly what you'd expect
what does it do
unknown
find me somewhere to plug in and i'll
try to find out
there we go plug me in over there
interesting
this structure has been activated using
a protocol that's far older than
anything i've ever seen
it
it knows we're here welcome welcome oh
hello i am adjutant resolution
sub-monitor of this installation loyal
servant of despond empire who must be
indisposed if i have been activated have
you seen her
kinda
do you want to tell him tell me what the
monitor is gone
gone
gone
but it wasn't us are you sure
of course it wasn't us good
good
good i was worried you were perhaps
unfriendly as you can see this fire has
been successfully deployed this way i
presume you wish to see the observation
platform
see he seems friendly
we'll see
did you say something
no
there is much to see
i was created i just want empire as a
friend not a replacement
strange times
oh
i'm sorry the portal should have been
activated one moment
into the portal
one moment
let us proceed
this is very
exciting
and the reformation can begin
there we are
as you can see we are ready to progress
as soon as
get me to that terminal
oh that's not so bad
the structure's purpose is simple
rebuild the ring
well more specifically create the
materials needed to repair it
not gonna happen
why
it's such a beautiful
oh the banished sorry i was distracted
for a second
there's so much to learn here shut it
down
permanently
no no no
what are you doing this is not
acceptable you were supposed to be
friendly
i've got you now
there we are back to it
you're going to break something
accounting for new variables
weapons
[Music]
you're in trouble now
[Music]
how dare you
i have good news and bad news
how many okay straight to the bad news a
lot i count nine no ten spires more
being deployed all the time
active no not yet at least they appear
to be waiting for an initialization
sequence something is flooding the
network trying to start it but there's
resistance
why
the protocol that triggered all this
wasn't exactly correct
it worked well it started the process
there's more bad news i can't shut it
down exactly
but i can remove it from the network
of course i can find the source of the
attack i just need to wait
is it safe come on it's me
an infiltration program designed
oops i think she knows i'm how are you
doing
disconnect give me one second to
get it now
it's done
why don't you trust me what was that
[Music]
maybe taking it offline wasn't such a
great idea we need to go like now
immediate extraction my location oh god
it was you wasn't it
now i'm coming i'm coming
oh come on
[Music]
open up
go
upload those fire locations all of them
all of them
um
it looks like someone has marked 42 new
locations which
would be crazy right
this one it was the source of the attack
attack
what's she talking about chief
is everyone trying to kill you
it kind of seems like it
oh wait
you're being sarcastic
he's fun i like him am i dead already i
must be i mean
this is a punishment right
yep this is death
no
no
no no
this isn't happening
i'm going to have to make an emergency
landing
hold on chief